Ali Dawa, like just about everyone in
the Da community, is a complete, utter,
total hypocrite. He invents whatever
rules he needs as he goes along, and it
never crosses his mind to be consistent
or to think about how the rules he's
inventing expose his own community or
his own fake profit. In case you don't
believe us, let's take a careful look at
exhibit 487 million, a video of Alidawa
complaining to Godlogic because God
logic doesn't do what Daagandists tell
him to do. My name is Abra. What's your
name? Abra. I call you not logic. Call
me Abra. We We ain't got to give it We
ain't got to give it. We would have. No,
no, we would have, but I heard that you
condone ripping the Quran. I I said it
under the right circumstances.
Interesting. And I believe in no
circumstances I will ever rip up the
Bible. Yeah. Fortunately, Alid Dawa,
other people don't decide what they are
going to do based on what you do. For
example, we wouldn't tell our 9-year-old
daughters that they're ready for
marriage.
If my daughter
at 9 years old, I would say you are
ready.
You are ready to get married. You are
ready to get married. you are ready to
get married. And we wouldn't send
messages to ex-Muslims telling them that
they are going to be executed as soon as
we get the political power. This isn't
part of our religion. There's a reason
to it. Yeah. There's a reason why
there's a capital punishment because
people like you, little weaklings who
leave their religion and cause uh
corruption in the land by spreading it,
the capital punishment in Islamic law
would be applied to you. We have no
doubt and we're proud of that. Yeah.
capital punish will be applied in an
Islamic state. So don't ever ever try to
convince us how we should act based on
how you act.
You're pretty much the opposite of
anything we would consider a standard of
morality.
If somebody if if somebody rips up the
Bible and then somebody I got you but if
if somebody rips up the Quran in return,
would you would you blame them? If
someone rips up the If somebody rips up
If somebody rips up the Quran in
response to somebody ripping the Bible,
would you would you condone that? Two
rooms don't make a right. Allah says in
the Quran. I know. Would you blame them
though? Yes. Oh, okay. Especially if
he's a Muslim. Well, as a Muslim, you
definitely shouldn't be ripping up any
Bibles because as you know, your God and
your prophet affirm the inspiration, the
preservation, and the authority of the
Jewish and Christian scriptures. So, as
a Muslim, you should respect our book as
your prophet did. But that has
absolutely nothing to do with how we
should treat your book, which we regard
as the ramblings of an illiterate 7th
century Arabian caravan robber who
married a six-year-old girl. Now, if
someone rips up the Quran and in return
somebody rips up the Bible, he's going
against the Quran because the Quran
says, I I know, repel evil with that
which is good. So, with us, we don't
believe two two wrongs make a right. Two
wrongs don't make a right, but three
rights make a left, don't they?
My thing is this to you. Yesterday we
had a I would have a nice cordial
discussion with you. We did because you
came to me polite and this that. But the
thing is your reality is not that. If
your reality was that, bro, let me be
honest with you. I have a nice single
life. That is how I am. No, you know,
you condone ripping the Quran. I
condone. I condemn anyone that rips the
Bible. Not that we have anyways. So
anyways, you are as bad as the ones that
ripped. But this is my point though. My
point is is that your Quran says do not
mock those who invoke other than Allah.
Right. Lest they will mock Allah in
return. Right. So what I'm saying is is
that the Quran warns Muslims of
provoking the people to certain actions
when they mock. Right. Exactly. So what
I'm saying is is as a Muslim if you see
that a Christian responds right in let's
say ripping the Quran or mocking
Muhammad or or Allah. God logic brings
up a verse in the Quran where Allah
orders Muslims not to mock the beliefs
of non-Muslims if it's going to cause
non-Muslims to mock the beliefs of
Muslims. The verse is surah 6 verse 108
which reads, "Do not revile those whom
they call upon apart from God, lest they
should revile God out of enmity without
any knowledge. As we have made the deeds
of every community seem fair unto them,
then unto their Lord shall be their
return, and he will inform them of that
which they used to do. So God logic is
saying in effect, if it's the behavior
of Muslims that's causing non-Muslims to
desecrate the Quran, then according to
the Quran, that's on Muslims. If your
behavior causes non-Muslims to react
negatively and you know your behavior
causes non-Muslims to react negatively
and you behave like that anyway, you
should be blaming yourself, not
non-Muslims, for the way that people are
reacting. This is especially true for
Ali Dawa because he constantly,
endlessly, relentlessly mocks the
beliefs of Christians and yet he whines
like a baby when Christians react.
Hypocrite.
You condone the ripping of the Quran
only in context only as a response to to
said action. Listen, we Muslims are the
whatever you want to call it the
terrorists and we are anti-pric for some
odd reason. For some odd reason, we as
Muslims, you don't rip the Bible. Yeah,
you guys be stepping on the Bible all
the time. What are you talking about?
You don't rip the Bible because your God
and your prophet affirm the inspiration,
the preservation, and the authority of
the Bible. You lie about what your God
and your prophets say, and you pretend
the Quran says the Bible was corrupted.
But you know that even if the Bible has
been corrupted, which the Quran never
says, you still have to believe that at
least some of the Bible is the inspired
word of Allah. So you don't want to rip
the inspired word of Allah. If you
didn't believe that, you'd have no
problem desecrating the Bible. How do I
know? Because we know that Muhammad
demonstrated his contempt for other
people's religious beliefs by
desecrating what they believed in. In
Sah Bkari 2478, Muhammad conquers Mecca
and what does he do? The prophet entered
Mecca and at that time there were 360
idols around the Cabba. He started
stabbing the idols with a stick he had
in his hand and reciting truth Islam has
come and falsehood disbelief has
vanished.
Muhammad went around stabbing the idols
of the polytheists.
Why? To insult and mock and degrade
them. Was that wrong, Alidawa? If you
say it's wrong and immoral for
non-Muslims to desecrate the Quran, why
is it perfectly acceptable for Muhammad
to desecrate the idols of non-Muslims?
Where's the consistency?
You don't have any. With that said,
there are Muslims who desecrate the
Bible. Aki X is a is a Muslim on Tik
Tok. You g you ask me who. I'm giving
you an example. If you don't know him,
that that's on you. AX he ripped up
pages in the Bible and put him in the
toilet. Tell me any brother in the Dawa
scene who is known. What do you mean in
the Dawa scene? Everybody on TikTok
knows him. I repeat again. I You're not
going to get me some random guy
somewhere. You ask me who. So Ali Darw
claims Muslims don't desecrate the
Bible. And God logic points out that
there are Muslims who desecrate the
Bible. In fact, it's not terribly
uncommon. It happens in Pakistan. It
happens in Iran. It happens in Malawi.
So Ali Dawa has to modify his claim and
say well but the popular dais in western
nations don't do it as if dawa guys are
a supreme moral standard in Islam and in
the world listen to me has been me hijab
what does I got to do no no no has any
of them ever disrespected the Bible by
ripping it not I've seen that I've seen
but that doesn't matter you ask me who
Ali Dawa brings up his partner in Slime
Muhammad Hijab. We're supposed to be
more like Muhammad Hijab. Apparently,
Muhammad Hijab, of course, is currently
embroiled in a scandal for keeping
secret hotel wives and for blackmailing
a shake and for using a photoshopped
screenshot and an AI generated fake
confession to discredit one of his
victims. Hijab sends messages to us
about golden showers, which should give
you some idea of the kinds of things
he's into. He sends messages to atheists
advising them to end their own lives. He
says that deep down women who criticize
Islam are actually hoping that these da
guys would conquer them and have their
way with them. He says, "I believe
certain anti-Muslim women would wish
they lived in the medieval period, a
period where if a war was won by the
opposing side, it was conventional that
people could be taken as booty. Some
historical accounts actually say some
women would dress up for the captor.
And he doesn't just address non-Muslims
this way. Look at what he says to his
fellow Muslims. Okay. Can I suck your
wife's pit to make her mum?
This is the guy whose example we're all
supposed to follow. Alidawa. And
speaking of Alidawa, should we make our
wives communicate using a whiteboard?
But she's going to have her say um with
this whiteboard that I bought her.
Okay, there's something my wife wants to
say. Uh Salama probably had enough as
woman give out. Okay, she's saying she
made the video, not him. I don't know
his opinion. But back to Ali Dawa
whining to God logic. I deal with
Muslims all the time. I think more than
what you do cuz I do the, you know,
debate every day. So I see what Muslims
do. And if I see Muslims be
disrespectful to the Holy Spirit,
disrespectful to Jesus, and it garers a
response to Christians, I have no
problem with a Christian responding to
Muslim action by even if even if it's
ripping the Quran only if it's cursing
God. If you if they curse God, ripping
the Quran is on the table for them. So
God logic says that if someone is
responding to terrible behavior by
ripping the Quran, he doesn't have a
problem with it. And he's already
connected this to what the Quran says in
surah 6 verse 108 of the Quran. Allah
tells Muslims that if their behavior is
causing someone to attack Islam, they
should change their behavior. So why is
complaining about what Allah says? I
will never say or giving encourage and I
would condemn if somebody is going
around ripping Qurans just for the sake
of it with under under no um you like
for no reason. Okay? You know what I'm
saying? So nobody should be doing that.
But if people are cursing, if Muslims
are cursing the Holy Spirit, cursing our
God, then they get what they do. They
they get what comes of it. No problem.
Okay. You say no problem. God logic says
that he would have a problem with people
ripping up the Quran for no reason, but
that if someone rips up a Quran in
response to blasphemy from Muslims, he
doesn't have a problem with it. It's
important to note, of course, that the
Quran is filled with blasphemy.
Draw your own conclusions.
What would Jesus do? In in what regard?
Argument. Let's go for argument sake.
Muslims, they rip the Bible. They rip
the Bible. Would Jesus do the same? I
don't know. Maybe. I I think actually
what Jesus would do, he would go up to
the Muslim and call him Which one? Which
one? This is what he'll do. What What
Jesus would do is he'll go to a Muslim.
He'll go to a Muslim. He'll go up to the
Muslim and he'll call him a snake and a
viper and a hypocrite because they claim
to follow him. And then they point the
finger at others while they reject who
he is and reject his words. So that's
what he'll do. Ali Dawa raises an
interesting question. What would Jesus
do? Would Jesus rip up a Quran? God
logic says we don't know. Why? Because
the issue never comes up in the Gospels.
So we can't say what Jesus would do. But
we do know how Jesus responds to
hypocrisy. He responds with extremely
harsh rebuke, even mockery and insults.
Read Matthew 23. So, we don't know what
Jesus would do if he was confronted by
an antichrist book designed to lead
people away from the truth. But we do
know that he rebuked hypocrites like Ali
Dawa and his fellow Dawagandists. Jesus
would condemn them for their hypocrisy
and for their secret hotel wives and for
blackmail and for making their wives
communicate through whiteboards and so
on. At the end of the day, this is just
a really weird thing for Ali Dawa to
complain about. His book calls us the
worst of creatures. Surah 98:6.
Verily those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam, the Quran and Prophet
Muhammad from among the people of the
scripture, Jews and Christians and al-
Mushrakun, Mushrakun are people who
associate partners with Allah will abide
in the fire of hell. They are the worst
of creatures. The Quran calls Jews and
Christians the worst of creatures. The
Quran commands Muhammad's followers to
violently subjugate us. The Quran lies
about what we believe and it lies about
Jesus. And yet, we're supposed to
respect it. Why? Why would we respect a
book that says we have to be violently
subjugated?
We have no reason to respect the Quran,
especially when it causes these da
clowns to act like total hypocrites.
The reason we usually wouldn't rip up
the Quran is that we just don't like the
idea of ripping up books. We think it's
silly. We prefer better forms of
criticism. We prefer responding to silly
claims by refuting them. So why is it
becoming more and more common for people
to desecrate the Quran?
It's because of the behavior of people
like Ali Dawa. They go around bragging
about how Islam's going to rule the
world and how they're going to execute
people for leaving Islam and how they're
going to execute people for criticizing
Islam and how they're going to legalize
child marriage. People who wouldn't
ordinarily desecrate a book are starting
to desecrate the Quran as a form of
protest. It's a reaction to awful
behavior. The Quran somehow gives people
like Ali Dawa the idea that since they
obey the ramblings of an illiterate 7th
century Arabian caravan robber who
married a six-year-old girl, they get to
control the rest of us. The rest of us
don't want to be controlled by people
like Ali Dawa, especially when they tell
us we have to respect their book. So
Alidawa, you need to take a step back
and look in the mirror. People aren't
ripping up your book because they like
ripping up books. And they're not
ripping up your book because they're
evil. They're ripping up your book
because you're evil. And everyone's
getting sick of your idiotic nonsense.
You want to control the world. But you
and your band of da flunkies only
control two things right now. Jack and
squat. And Jack just left town. By
ripping up the Quran, people are letting
you know that you don't control them. We
are not, have never been, and never will
be your demise. And the more you run
around complaining about it, the more
you're going to realize people just
don't care about protecting the book
that gave rise to the grooming gangs.
And if you and your gaggle of
narcissistic, homicidal perverts in the
Dawa scene don't like that, you have my
full permission to cry me a river.
You pride on that. You pride on that.
You just back fine on me. You pride on
that. You pride on that. You proud on
that. You just back fine on me. This is
a powerful religion. There's a reason to
it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.